[Music]
Runk Colona BC Vancouver uh I'm coming
uh Rochester New York dude I added new
shows check it out I added new shows in
yeah we got the Corpus Christie dates we
got Houston Texas Durham North Carolina
and norfol but um I added Grand Rapids
Michigan Fort Wayne Indiana a place
called Sagen Michigan for some reason V
Toria BC I added Augusta Georgia and
Chattanooga Tennessee those are the um
places that I added uh just
recently um now so uh go to chris.com
and get those tickets get the good seats
I only sell a 100 meet and greets each
show everyone's always like where the
meet and greets the day before and I'm
like oh well they I'm not gonna I can't
meet everybody but I appreciate you guys
um go to chris.com and get those tickets
it's all new material not from grow or
diey but you can also go watch grow or
diey at christ.com
um anyway this is
[Music]
congratulations my son woke up this
morning crying and ran into my room and
said dad I got a boo boo in my tongue I
guess he bit it and I go son me
too and we
bonded
uh and he hasn't said anything about it
since so that's fine and I have actually
complained about mine so I bit my I bit
my tongue yes D it I bit my tongue um
and not in the uh what do you call it
sense in the actual physical sense I I
bit my tongue but um anyway that doesn't
you know it's really neither here nor
there I'm excited to get there dude I'm
playing a lot of cities that I've never
played before uh I think they're making
cities up my tour manager is making
cities up and telling me that we're
going there because I don't know what
sagam Michigan is but I'm going to go
dude and I hope people show up and I
here's the thing dude there's so many
cities out there and comedians play
Boston Austin and everything that rhymes
with that you know they'll do Vancouver
they'll do Tech they'll do uh uh uh you
know they might do El dude I did El Paso
and
honestly uh they
were
the most appreciative people it was it
was act actually very sweet and
refreshing during the meet and greet
they were just like thank you so many
people said thank you for coming to El
Paso and people don't really say that
when you go to their City because they
think their City's the [__] because
they're in their City everybody always
thinks their city is the the [__] it's
it's a it's absolutely Bonkers actually
because guess what there are bad cities
did you know that there's bad cities cuz
I went from El Paso to albu Kade now let
me tell you something okay we know about
my storyed history with with Al
Albuquerque we know about my Feud dude
it runs deeper than the Nicki Minaj uh
uh Megan the stallion Feud okay it runs
real deep it's like on some Tupac Biggie
stuff right and I have I don't have beef
with albuquer all right I just tweeted
about it once in 2019 about how I think
I said something like Albuquerque makes
Jacksonville look like paradise and I
was on the news they were talking to
people on the street we we' talked about
this before on my podcast go back you
know you can you can look at the videos
the rest somewhere just chrisly
Albuquerque anyway I went back to
Albuquerque why because I need because
dude I if I
talk crap about your city I'm still I'm
GNA come even more so because I don't
want you to think that I'm I don't want
you to think that I'm scared because I'm
not dude if I die on stage I die on
stage dude you know I'm like one of
those uh you
know veterans that's like I need to get
back out there and start shooting you
know foreign enemies I just I can't
that's my life dude I'll get out there
if I die on stage I die on stage that's
the life I that's the life I live that's
a life I chose you know what I'm talking
about but um so I went to Albuquerque
and I was like dude I wonder if it's
going to get because people I've gotten
many when I say many I mean
nine no I'm I'm I'm actually kidding it
was way more than nine messages about
comments you know hey dude you better
not come to Albuquerque I'll find you
and kick your that kind of stuff like
like straight
up um that usually doesn't worry me
because if somebody's going to kick your
ass they're not going to give you heads
up about it you know what I'm talking
about if somebody's going to shoot you
in the head they don't want they don't
want you on guard right so they're not
going to tell you if I say hey dude
gonna kill you you go I'm you know what
I mean you get ready I don't go I'm G to
kill you I say hey bud that's nice do
you like sandwiches and then stab you in
the face right you think about
sandwiches you had no idea this was
coming um
so so anyway um I went to Albuquerque
and it's always the funniest thing about
cities that are are bad are and by the
way say we want about it here here's I
don't und there's like a spectrum right
of cities that are bad that have to the
locals will be like yeah but there's a
lot of beautiful Parts here you know
like that's how you know you're in a
really shitty City well actually there's
a lot of really good hiking here right
like that's what they'll say and you're
like all right dude but yeah the city
sucks you know um and then and then
they'll be
like the the the more offended you get
the worse the city right like if I say
Albuquerque
sucks people go yo don't come here this
is my city [__] you
IM Matt do people talk [__] about La all
the time I couldn't care less and also
La kind of does suck depending on your
mind frame and who you are okay so just
agree with me Albuquerque is what it is
the crowd was actually the crowd was
pretty drunk but it was nice the crowd
was good you know there were a few
people that popped off we had a good
time I mean of course you're going to be
drunk in Albuquerque
of course you're going to do that
because that's you know that's it that
art that like art that what is it like
that me Mexican art that they have
everywhere everything's turquoise and
like deeply like beige
red that those colors suck together you
know um they do dude and they'll just
have like a circle with like three lines
out the top three lines out to side
three lines out the other side three
lines out the bottom I'm like that's not
really like that good you know but
that'll be everywhere what is that thing
who knows what that thing is the circle
with the three lines above it three
lines below it three lines out the sides
too and they just plaster it on
everything it'll be on just like the
street corners but also flyers and like
people will have it just decaled on
their car hey dude that's just a circle
with some lines
man but they live by it they love it and
then they'll be like yeah that's
actually I'm sure it's like so shitty
for me to even talk bad about it they're
like you actually don't make fun of that
because that mean that's our ancestors
are the thing and I'm like yeah okay all
right you know right it's a circle with
some lines in it anyway
dude they were good shows Albuquerque
was cool and I'll keep going back to Al
albuquer all right I'll keep going um
and it was fun and Al Paso was good but
uh yeah dude I got a bunch of new cities
coming up and I'm going to do them all
and it's going to be absolutely Bonkers
I don't
know Rick Ross has a a plane engine
coffee table so it's like I got to keep
working until I can get a plane engine
coffee
table I I I I what what what happens to
rappers dude like what are rappers doing
you know what I'm saying like when you
get to the certain point like like
Nell's missing out you know Nelly needs
to what is Nelly doing not on Instagram
doing like what up this is my house and
like with a flamethrower why is he not
if he's doing that he would be so I
guess I guess that's the thing though
you if you were making if you made that
much money why would you even do that I
guess I want to stay relevant but Rick
Ross just made a this I'm going to go
ahead and play the worst Instagram video
of all time for you guys just because
why not but this is the uh this is Rick
Ross that and he got a a a plane engine
this I just had my table delivered been
waiting on this a long time guess what I
did this is my amazing brunch area so
lonely this is my amazing brunch area
dude even having a brunch area is crazy
when you're like is he married is Rick
Rick Rick Ross Rick Ross Ross
wife hold on a
second oh he's engaged okay Rick Ross
have a wife and kids Ross would really
engage no he's not engaged anymore okay
so Rick Ross is gay cuz if you have a
brunch table and you're not married
you're if you have a brunch
area and you have no wife that's fine
you suck dicks and that's all good but
you do that absolutely right but guess
what we did I bought a motor from a 757
ainer that's right in Airplane a
757 airliner had the blades polished had
the lights inserted I could change the
lights any color I want to had the
taable top the top glass cut
this is custom this is a Ricky Ros
customization Ricky Ros request and this
brunch are is just for enjoying the
finest spirits of course Luke B dude it
sounds his mouth sounds so juicy it's
making me thirsty is that
weird just has so much drool coming out
of it McQueen bumo Von right in front of
my one of my favorite fish tanks that
you can see on both sides of the wall
and wow we pulled it off shout out to my
team it's amazing I'm happy I'm F to
have me a glass of uh bum boo of course
I'm going have a glass of bum dude him
just sitting
drinking like alcohol on his me if you
want to know how much I spin on this you
know salute to the team for making this
happen dude I'm going to I'm going to
ask him how much he I'm going to ask him
I'm going to DM him right now I'm going
to DM Rick Ross right now how much did
you spend on the on the uh um on the uh
what what do I say on
the um Rich
Forever how much did you spend I'm going
to do a voice note actually here yo yo
I'm just Cur I honestly I honestly want
to know how much you spent on uh the
airline table or the the the air engine
table you said dmu and I think it's like
it's got to be a lot of money
right but I mean it's nothing to you but
still anyway let me know if if you said
DM you
ask that's the first time I ever reached
out to Rick Ross so there we go we'll
get back to you there uh on that and
we'll let you know how much he spent on
his airline coffee table it's by the way
crazy that you can just reach anyone huh
dude I'd be so mad if I was Rick Ross
and Chris deyah sent me a voice note I'd
be angry I'd hire a hitman you know like
that's so that is yeah that's I regret
that I did it but I'm not going to
unsend it um anyway anyway um yeah I
wonder how much whatever it is what it
is
um the [__] dudy thing is crazy
huh the the the the George Carlin AI but
by the way is fantastic and Chad culin
wrote it I know he did because he's a
writer and I know that he did that and
they pretended it was AI of course and
that's fine but then
George Carlin's estate sued him because
they're saying they're using his V you
know an AI generator voice and
pretending like it's him and I guess
they're making money off of YouTube of
this thing which
is
uh I go back and forth on it
like you're gonna use someone's
voice voice to make money I guess that
person should get the money right but
it's also not their voice but it is
cataloges of their voice
then put out into
the world as them so it is their
likeness their voice likeness right so I
guess they should get some money let's
just figure this out
um but everyone knows it's not George
Carlin I mean except for some idiots you
know that are probably
like like I had a bit on on Instagram
that was that where I was said my son's
my son's white and then somebody
literally commented like I don't
understand he's white why would his son
not be white is his did he have was he
with a mix race person or something or
like and it's just like oh my god
dude
huh so um people like that would maybe
see it and be like no this has to be
George Carlin but like it's not George
Carlin it's Chad couchin writing it and
doing it I really it it's like the first
of its kind lawsuit kind of like I I
just wonder I wonder what the hell will
happen but anyway it was amazing Chad
did a great job job and then
um and then yeah I don't know what's
going to happen though how do you make
how do you they're going to sue him
anyway
whatever there's going to be so much
fake [__] out there it's going to be
unbelievable like just videos of people
I saw somebody sent me a PCT a video of
a of a chick on a bed in a bikini and
they're like this is AI and and I and I
actually still don't believe it it's not
they sent it to me and I said no it's
not Ai and they're like it is AI and I
was like no it's not and I don't think
it is so there you go I'm old I don't
believe in the technology I believe in
the technology but I don't believe the
technology is there yet so I'm old I'm
basically you know somebody who's ad on
Facebook that is like clicking on some
military guy's message because I think
he thinks I have a crush on him or
because he I think he has a crush on me
because he's talking to me flirting with
me and I'm going to alope with him and
then he's going to scare me out of money
almost happened to my
mom just kidding she's married but you
know what I
mean
um so yeah I don't know man just trying
to you know navigate through life you
guys are good I was at I was working out
today and dude it was
absolutely I don't know what was going
on but I'm weak and I'll admit it I'm
weak dude I tried to do squats I'm weak
I tried to do sing Single Leg uh rear
foot elevated split Spots I'm weak I
tried to do deadlifts I'm weak then I
the squats and I'm
weak and I'm pissed dude at it I'm
pissed at it man I can't [__] squat
more and I want to squat more it gets me
angry dude whatever man I hope people at
the gym don't listen to this podcast
because I don't want them to see me
struggling and know my secret life about
talking about the gym on
podcasts I don't like that somebody came
up to me today and they were like hey
man I listen to your podcast and I just
got like genuinely like oh [__] I wonder
which one he listened to recently I'm
such a dick I'm a piece of [__] great
great great that's a tape that plays on
my head great are you insecure like me
what's
up
um I don't
know I want to talk about this is what I
want to talk about one of the number one
things I want to talk about CU this is
such a thing we would talk about on
congratulations and by we I mean me I
don't and I don't understand it and I'll
never understand it and actually I do
understand it do you understand what I'm
saying
um Barbie like he here's the thing if
you stay offline you don't know that
people are upset that Margot Robbie
didn't get nominated for Barbie all
right I didn't know that I'm pretty
offline all right my wife is like have
you heard about this Barbie [__] I was
like no what is it she was like people
are really outraged that Margot Robbie
didn't get nominated and then Ryan
gossing did get nominated
and so I look it up and you know it's 3%
of the people on Twitter that absolutely
make it seem like it's you know an
outrage which it's not but they
are I I I mean I can't believe their
argument is so
invalid and their argument is wow this
movie did so well how could it not get
nominated for best director how could it
not get nominated for best actress
Margot Robbie when it was so good made
so much
money and Ry then Ryan Gosling got
nominated like they're like oh here come
the men again everyone loves Men first
of all have you ever read anything
online
lately men men are the devil okay so
drop that drop it cuz people don't you
know yeah okay men have some privileges
I guess but then so women have other
ones right but Ryan
Gosling
is I didn't see the movie and I should
see the movie but I won't see the movie
right so I'm going to develop an opinion
about it because I didn't see it and
that's truly the way to watch a movie
and talk about it nowadays but
I Ryan gossing is great I'm sure margar
Robbie was great okay anyone is lucky
enough to get nominated in that movie
that's probably not the best one of the
best movies of the Year okay and just
because it made a lot of money doesn't
mean it's one of the best pictures of
the Year okay often that means it sucks
all right you know what movies made a
lot of
money fast and the furious
Transformers Captain
Marvel these [__] movies they're not
going to get nominated no one gives a
[__] about them except for like you know
popcorn eaters they go and they have a
good time or you watch it on your couch
but nobody's nominating Vin Diesel for
fast X cuz it
sucks cuz he sucks now that doesn't mean
Margot Robbie sucks Mar Margot Robbie's
good but my point is all more often than
not a movie that makes a billion dollars
sucks all right and it's also not the
kind of movie that gets nominated
really but Ryan gossing did get
nominated okay so fine oh isn't that
just ironic because the point that
Barbie makes is how this and that and
the other thing and now it's happening
in real life that's what people are
saying now look at that everything that
Barbie shed light on it's all for not
because Ryan Goslin got nominated margar
Robbie didn't okay well check this out
dude what about that other chick that
got nominated America Ferrara I think
that's her name even though that's not a
name she got nominated for Bobby right
what's her
name yeah she got nominated for Barbie
okay so oh so you're leaving that out so
you're leaving out that actually a woman
got nominated in Barbie they actually
did get nominated in Barbie it's just
margar Robie didn't get nominated and
you don't just
want some of the you you don't want
equality you want more that's that's the
problem with equality right what is
equal what is
equal what is equal if you have one of
something and one of another thing
that's equal but there isn't one of
there's millions and billions of things
there's billions of people there's
billions of food there's billions of
cars there's so many billion things so
getting all that equal is impossible all
right people aren't going to be equal
there's going to be different power
dynamics with different people and then
also that has nothing to do with why
Ryan gossing got nominated all right
Ryan gossing is great marel Robbie's
great too but also
spie it's
Barbie it's a toy I think there should
be a rule that you shouldn't be not able
to get nominated for a [__] movie
about a
toy I'm sure it's
goodish but you can't say what the [__]
here the men go
again here the men go again of course I
you know what I've had
KU well
America Ferrara got nominated yeah but
we're we want them we want more it makes
no sense the argument falls on his face
and most people understand that remember
when they made the the movie a while ago
with that
woman uh uh who got nominated that
everyone was like outraged that she
there was this woman that was in a movie
that barely no one
saw yes Andrea Andrea rise borrow um and
and what was the movie Nowhere girl or
something to
Leslie so this movie just somehow got
nominated because she's great and she
actually is a great actress okay she got
nominated and there was such an and by
such an I mean the 3% of the people on
Twitter that were making a big thing
about this they were
saying it was controversial
because
well let's just call it the way how it
is is because she was a white woman and
people were mad that other people of
color didn't get nominated when she did
and nobody even saw this
movie
so
so they bent the Oscars bent and did an
investigation about if they could do if
they could have uh if the campaign was
legit if the Oscar campaign was is legit
dude an Oscar campaign is about
popularity and money it costs you know
it costs like I think it cost $20,000 to
put your movie in for best picture or
something like it's part of the budget
it's a lot of money hey dude if it costs
that much it's crooked okay it's crooked
all right the best the best Oscar goes
to doesn't matter it's crooked
right like so the fact that that person
got nominated they put an investigation
on the [__] because they were like well
there's a way to get nominated and they
kind of must have scared around it if
the academy voted for
her are we making our money we want to
be making our money we can't just have
Andrea
risborough get nominated but she's Fant
here's the AR here's the other thing
she's
fantastic she's fantastic I get it if it
was Vin Diesel getting nominated then
you could be like dude this is a COC of
[__] because he sucks another thing
another white
man but it's Ryan Gosling and he's great
see
you
um I can't I mean all the awards are
such a Croc of [__] it
sucks and
uh and you can put that on my
Tombstone you could put it on my
tombstone
I love this dude how Taylor Swift liking
football here how about this for
equality chicks Taylor Swift uh now
because she is dinkin Kelce or whatever
his name what's his name Travis
Kelce that they have generated three the
NFL has generated $300 million all
because of dinkin That's crazy
dude Travis
Kelce and Taylor Swift dink NFL $300
million NFL Travis Kelsey
goes and Taylor Swift goes uh and then
NFL straight up cing $300 million ain't
that crazy dude ain't that crazy so
how's that for equality
huh chicks just buying Travis Kelce gear
buying you know cutting away to do they
cut away
to teror Swift so much dude
she looked at the camera the other day
and she says she mouth go away or leave
me alone or something that's gangster I
like that so now I'm a fan of hers but
it's just
like
that's it's just a business huh right
isn't it the craziest [__] everything's
a business God that it really is
disheartening you know but hey
capitalism but hey capitalism what's up
you know it's all good I'm no communist
hey capitalism what's up you know I
don't think we should share everything
equ hey capitalism what's up I'm
grateful for capitalism that's why
people come to my shows thanks very much
capitalism um but yeah dude imagine
dinking somebody makes the imagine you
just straight up start a relationship
and then you make the NFL $300 million
God D I would if I were Taylor Swift hey
dude guess what I would be the I would
think I hope she thinks she's better
than everyone I really do deep down I
hope deep down she thinks I hope deep
deep down she has thoughts during the
day where she's like where she actually
thinks and feels when she drives by
someone and she's looking at them and
she thinks that person's a piss
an I hope I that would make me happy if
she thought that you
know you ever see her dance she kills it
um but yeah dude Travis Kelce everyone
thinks he's hot he's cool
[Music]
um and uh I don't know anything about
them to be pretty honest I know nothing
about them I know shake it off and
that's all I
know but uh Taylor Swift
huh it's crazy how much love and then
hate she
gets and people are like oh she's mid
you know you can't get to the Top If
you're not mid dude you can't get to the
upper echelon of you can't make a
billion dollars a night on tour if
you're not
mid if you're that good people the the
the population won't like you because
the population is
mid make makes sense makes
Sensational makes Sensational but yeah
dude
um I mean there's there's outliers and
there's there's outliers that are big
and there are also you know uh what do
you call it um exceptions to the rule
but also if you're that
big you know and she has talent right
it's not that she's you know whatever
but I'm just saying Taylor Swift and Hal
Hal Bailey deserve their privacy just
like we all do look at this look at this
[__] headline on C on CNN dude what
the [__] with
CNN CNN will have a headline and it'll
just be like chairs what do we think of
them it's like this is news you
know chair chairs too many that's a
that's a that's a headline for
CNN here we go how would you feel if
complete strangers publicly analyze all
specs of your life look at this dude
look at this look at this article how
would you feel if complete strangers
publicly analyze all aspects of your
life and use your name in all manner of
stories or product campaigns that had
little or nothing to do with you when it
comes to the world of celebrities there
can sometimes be a sense they belong to
the public yeah no [__] okay been there
sucks how about this though you doing
[Music]
it hey you're doing it hey CNN you're
reporting about them you're doing it
also ALS Al who's hie
Bailey I know
nothing is she on like uh she's probably
the new person on like they're revamping
the Teenage Witch or some [__] Little
Mermaid really who who but who's cares
about what she's like she's not
big is she
big she they throw a fit when they yeah
when when she got Ariel right because
she's black I love it make Ariel black I
don't care do it make I think every role
in everything should only be black
people I I think that
100% genuinely zero whes should have any
acting jobs only blacks only black women
too and they have to be a man they have
to have a mustache like a fake one a
really bad fake
one
um yeah look there was quite the upro
after the New York Times published an
opinion piece which speculated about
whether Taylor Swift may be closeted as
a queer person
you
know look at this swifties are are
awesome dude that's why I love that's
that's why I I I'm a
Swifty I don't
care I just think that
that's I do think that they should leave
people alone but they're not going to
so um DC
Drano tweeted this and uh he tweeted
dear San Francisco 49ers I know we've
all been roasting your city for years
but I am offering a two- week truce who
the [__] is DC
Dro some guy oh um a two-e truce no more
jokes about poop on the streets and open
air drug markets no calling out the
record levels of homelessness that Ma
magically disappeared for three days to
welcome a communist dictator
um none of that for two weeks 99% of
America will be 49ers fans but in return
you must defeat the
Chiefs this guy this guy's been watching
too much Inspector Gadget you know he's
like that guy the claw claw guy whatever
if you don't Mr fizer and his girlfriend
are going to tour the country as world
champions helping elect Joe Biden you
know didn't check with anybody on this
just making it up not going to work
World War III will likely follow in a
second Biden term and million will die
the fate of the Free World Rush upon
your shoulders no
pressure
bro people are nuts
huh
also San Francisco
bro I actually did see did see someone
[__] in between two mailboxes when I
was in San Francisco once so I did and I
go whoa dude they're making a delivery
he was [__] hold it he pulled his
pants down between two mailboxes taking
a [__] grump and it was so gross and
you had to hand it to him when a guy's
like I'm gonna make this area my toilet
and you're around he's not like in
private that dude's gangster and you
just got to hand it to
him I've told you this before La one
time dude by the way San Francisco been
that way people are talking about it now
ever since 2020 like how it's bad San
Francisco been that way it's a capital
of people crying in cars it's a capital
of it you just walk by somebody in the
street on the street you you cross you
cross the crosswalk you look at the
first car there is a 15% chance that
person is going to be crying just in the
car it's the saddest place to cry in
your car it's the place I've cried the
most but yeah man I saw people crying in
their car I saw somebody get robbed I
saw two people no joke this is serious
[__] in the street they were both men
that's real saw it guy pluging another
guy on the street not the sidewalk hey
guys
move [__] but
move seen it don't tell me I didn't see
it seen it I have my eyes I used them to
see it I'm still me I remember it
saw a guy shatter a glass door of a
checks class checks cashed
Place seen it saw guys get arrested seen
it in San Francisco all in the same week
and it was freezing yes San Francisco
well well you're probably well don't go
there in January I wasn't I was there in
August
dude San Francisco's always cold so
there you go it's always cold and people
are [__] in between mailboxes and
[__] in the street and slamming uh
doors and on check cash places and also
crying in cars 10 50% of people are
crying in
[Music]
cars yep so that's what's up dude but
anyway I'm not here to talk [__] about
cities even though I've talked [__]
about more cities in this podcast and I
have in any other
episode um I will be I am booking San
Francisco by the way so I will be there
so come on
out
um I'm back it was so hot I had to get
the air pump and we don't have a V this
from go I should do that but it's I
don't want to whatever you know what I
was in I was in
um I got back from the road uh yesterday
from
Albuquerque I should have known I I'm
such an idiot this is how much of an
idiot I am my so my friend Skyler Stone
sent me a screenshot of christen's my
wife's um story and said
he uh tell your wife to stop fixing your
house it's fine you know hahaa I'm like
oh yeah I know I know I didn't check the
story okay I didn't think about it I
just got that text and thought yeah
she's always doing that
stuff and
then I forgot
it and then I came home
and the whole wall the biggest wall in
her house is a different color now okay
which is fine but also check with me but
also I don't care but and then there is
a legit frame around R TV because she
saw it on Pinterest or something like
she made it she made the frame okay she
made it she made it gold and made it put
it together on the TV it looks kind of
nice I get home she's like I didn't I
hid you from my story I didn't want you
to see I hid you from your my story and
Sam from my story who's goes on the road
to me um I I I changed the house and I
go oh that's why [__] Skyler sent me
the thing I didn't didn't think it's how
dumb I am I didn't even think about
it and process it and like you know I
didn't let it marinate in my brain I
come home to a different house so she's
watching we're watching the um
the color's fine it looks all right the
the the the the we're watching on the TV
now that is now a a a picture frame um
we're watching the Chiefs game they
played the Ravens right
and I'm watching
it and Kristen
says it sucks man this broadcast uh is
not good and I'm like huh she's like
whoever transmitting the broadcast it's
getting it gets loud and then soft and
then loud and then quiet and it sucks so
say
oh yeah that's weird odd because it's
such a big game that they figure it out
and dial it in
yeah David Sullivan is over and he's
like oh really that's [__] weird
check other channels we didn't she goes
in the other room and I Look to David
and I'm like yo it's the frame
right it's covering up a [__] sensor
or something some [__] like that she
says she comes back and say babe it's
the frame she's like no no no no it's
been H it's been happening she said
before the
frame and I was like oh did it and it
and here's the thing about my did it did
it hey no it didn't and I know it didn't
and and she knows it didn't what so what
are we talking about here this is
[__]
why why don't we just start saying blal
floot because those are those make as
much sense as what we're saying right
now because it didn't happen before the
frame because the one thing that changed
since the volume was well what's
different what what two things are
different right now the volume's going
up and down and there's a frame around
our TV that's it that's it I'm still the
husband you're still the wife David is
still farting on a couch all right those
are the everything's the same so you
could argue that one has to do with the
other now the volume going up and down
didn't make the frame appear so what's
left
oh the frame is [__] up the
volume but you won't hear it so I say
okay hey look if it was happening before
it was happening before Sur you won't
lie about that it's all good we'll drop
it because I'm not going to con what i g
to do right cuz also the frame looks
nice I don't want her to feel bad it
actually does look
nice so we turn off the
game later on we turn on
Netflix the volume's going up and
[Music]
down he knew it dude I'm no Columbo I'm
no
Mentalist okay I'm no Woodward and
Bernstein but I figured it out you know
why I use deductive reasoning with my
simple brain I did it
okay the frame's still on it it's been
[__] two days the volume's going up
and down yes dude that's so what it's
like to be married that is so what it's
like to be married you know what I'm
talking about you're right you're right
and it's not worth it to even push it
you know what I'm talking about God it's
not worth it that's why I that's
why that's
why
I think
like bro I was on here here's here's
here's here's a great thing I was on
tour all right and my my tour manager I
was like I was scrolling through
Instagram right I follow a lot of
CrossFit people I I I see this uh
CrossFit woman who has got like crazy
abs like crazy ABS she has uh like it
looks like the the the bread um the
bread [__] buns you know what I'm
talking about just like popping out I
I've like never really seen abs like
this and I'm like God man this chick has
the craziest ABS they're really Define
and popping out and so my tour manager
is like oh let let me let me see like uh
you know if they're they're that good I
showed it to him and he goes well yeah
she she uh she she eats clean and she um
she works out a lot and I'm and I'm like
yeah yeah I know they're but they're
really great they're they're well-
defined and they're they're they're
they're really popping out and he says
well yeah but she's maintaining
it and I'm like yo I can't
pick something you would say that would
make me more
irate no [__]
dude I'm like I'm like oh yeah okay so
what are you saying he's like yeah so
I'm saying so I say are you not it's not
impressive and he's like no no I'm
saying so it is impressive so then what
the [__] you say she works out of course
she works out she's a CrossFit girl and
she [__] eats lean of course she eats
lean and she's always working out ABS so
what the [__] are we talking about here
and I did it and we got to that level
where I was just like in that zone of
like fun argument where I'm like if I
were doing this with
Kristen what end in
tears
mine ultimately right so I'm just like
man that felt good afterwards I thanked
him I'm like that felt good bro thanks
for letting me get that [__] out you
know I come home and I eat the frame
argument you
know a it's not no yeah of course it's
not the frame after you know I got it
out yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was like
it's like jerking off so you don't have
to have sex yeah yeah yeah no I'm
good dude the frame is making the the
the the the volume go oh it's not oh
okay that's okay I argued with Enrique
I'm all
good
insane dude being
married my first
marriage I was married when I was
younger I know I always clarify that but
um my my wife my ex-wife decorated the
house like honestly two chicks lived
there not a guy not a married couple and
that's and every time she would put
something new up like a [__] like a
beastro table or like a a a uh uh you
know curtains that like I wouldn't even
I would I'm like who are these like so
feminine I would I would be like oh man
my place is like pussified but then
immediately I would go like
this I don't I don't care that's that I
can't think of a more definition than
being married as a guy than that than
being like oh dude this thing happened
because my wife did it oh
cares because it's not worth and besides
that you also don't really care right
you know
why you're not a check right because
women do be decorating man they really
do
be um every time I come over from the
road something's different so that's
cool every time I come from the
something different I'm going to be I'm
going to come home from the RO one day
and be like open the door come in there
going be a different family be like what
the hell's going on what the oh Kristen
hey we did we
moved yeah yeah I was done with that
house I finished it I created what I
wanted to and now we're in another house
get ready for five more years of
decorating whatever and and you know
what here's me here's
me all
right they came with me to Phoenix I I I
did my Phoenix show two three weeks ago
and um two weeks ago whatever oh and I
have the video out the Brian K where I
CRA so I was in Phoenix and Brian K was
in Phoenix just by happen stance isn't
that crazy dude sometimes the Lord works
in mysterious ways I'm going to start
saying that a lot now and um he was in I
was in Phoenix and he was in Desert
Ridge which I you don't know I don't
know what the [__] that is but he I'm
always playing the actual spot and he's
always playing like 30 miles out of the
actual spot so uh I'm like all right
dude Sunday I'm going to stay and I'm
going to crash your show and he's like
oh okay so I came on Sunday and he was
like do a spot before me because I want
to work my hour and I want you to watch
it and I'm like I got to watch a [__]
hour he's like yeah cuz I want to know
what you think and I'm like I got to
[__] pay
attention now I do my spot did well it
was nice sat down watched about 40
minutes of his act and I'm like I'm
gonna go you know sit with Kristen I'm
like I'm gonna go backstage I don't want
to you know so I crashed
his I'm sitting backstage an hour and 20
minutes the guy
does I did [__] 20 he did an hour 20
and then another comic did 20 before me
hey audience you're held
hostage hey you're laughing right now
because you don't know what else to do
and by the way his hour is good it's
actually probably the best stuff I've
ever seen him
do but bring me he wanted me to come on
afterwards and [__] around with him
bring me on dude dude I'm back there
playing Royal match bring me on dude
yeah telling story after Story
okay that's fine but then cut out how
you wish you could kill a bear with your
bare hands you know what I'm talking
about dude hey leave that bit out Bring
me on so I went on and we roasted each
other for a while for like eight minutes
I put it on my YouTube channel so it's
on there you can go check it out um and
you know people are always like hey
start a podcast with Brian it'll be the
number one podcast you got to [__]
start it it's so funny I'd watch that
instead of this and that and dude first
of
all not necessarily second of
all dealing with Brian is
like it's it's so hard dude because you
you're like yeah 3:00 and then at 3:45
he's like I'm almost there and you're
like oh I'm just not I don't you know
maybe I'll do it maybe in the future
we'll do a a podcast but trying to
Wrangle him is just it's just he's got
his head up his whole
[__] Comics dude they're
crazy
we I did the show at the Improv last
night D David Lucas's show at the Improv
last night that dude is so great and
he's so funny and he's he's starting to
he sold out two shows at The Improv I
did both of them and the dude is just
really uh blowing up look out for him he
was I think he I think he blew up from
Kill Tony I think think but the guy's
great he roasts a lot of people which is
funny but also besides that he's great
uh but both of the things are great um
and it was just a fun hang dude you ever
like you ever go somewhere this is the
best right you go somewhere you don't
know what to expect it's going to be not
because you're like I wonder how it's
going to be but because you're not
thinking about it you're just like I'm
going to go and do that thing and then
that's it you start getting ready you
start driving you start getting there
and you don't think about the thing
you're just going through the motions
right and then you get there and then
all of a sudden things are like oh it's
that guy hey hey what's that oh yeah
chicken sandwich oh oh that's actually
really good oh cool hey I'm really
connecting with my wife oh this and that
going on oh cool oh ohy it's like oh
it's a nice new person I'm meeting and
then you got that moment in your head
where you're like hold
up this
rocks this is a ill
time hey you know what I'm
having a great time right now it's great
because it's unexpected you didn't know
it was going to be a great time but the
people were there the Hang was nice did
good sets that's cool watch some nice
comedy I don't watch it I didn't watch
it I don't watch anybody but
like I guess I'm I'm here to just say
like that unexpected good time oh dude
dude it's so dope and it that's why
Vegas always sucks because you're like
[__] yeah dude gonna win
5K and you
know if you're single gonna get sucked
off and
then you don't and you don't you lose 5K
and you jerk off at the Luxor and you're
not even staying at the
Luxor you know what I'm talking
about everybody has a podcast now it's
so annoying God damn it it's so goddamn
annoying I got three is Brendan Shaw
really quitting standup I don't I I
don't think he is but he said he's going
to stop doing it for a while um and uh
and because of it everything going on
with his family I I understand that dude
actually because um he needs you know
being there we get three kids and then
he had the medical issues with his with
his
newborn I'd shut [__]
down but since that's not happening I'll
be in
Chattanooga uh and Vancouver but yeah
dude
that's hey if you're making a grip on
the podcasts who cares just do
podcasts you don't have to go anywhere
maybe I'm jealous that's the thing dude
if I made
well obviously I make money doing
podcast but bro
if if I made $100 million bro not that
he did but I'm just saying you'd never
see me again dude you'd never [__]
see me again and I mean this with the
utmost sincerity you wouldn't see me on
the internet you also more importantly
wouldn't see me anywhere and I'm talking
to friends if you're listening to this I
would just be in my house Postmates
amazoning bro with sitting on money like
legitimately physically sitting on money
dude I would be done I'd be with my wife
my kids I have more kids I'd have 50
kids I'd invite people over if they
wanted to come over if they didn't if
they said no let's go see a movie i' go
like
this if you'd like to make a call please
hang up and try again message
C5 I'm not [__] with you bro by bye
the second I make a 100 Millie
bye I call everyone I go no I don't I
don't I don't call everyone I change my
aling message to bye that's what I do I
tweet bye I threads bye I put up an
Instagram video where it's me going bye
I get on only fans I show my [__] I say
bye I'm done dude subscribe for free on
my only fans bye [__] out just rubbing
off on in the kitchen bye I'll be here
from now on
never see again some of my friends oh
hell yeah and feel good about it
dude dude what's up what about
um Nick Minaj and mega the stallion I I
alluded to it early on but they got a
beef going or what I love how when it's
like beef explained the Washington Post
dude I give up this is on the [__]
Washington Post beef explained you know
Megan the stallion released her biting
song h on Friday a Punchy diss track
that tast a at the haters and critics
she's encountered through her career she
mened Mariah Carey and Chris Jenner on
the in just on the track while appearing
to make point of references to Drake and
her ex-boyfriend Tory Lanes but her
words stung for Nicki Minaj no news is
news anymore are you kidding
me wow
and then Minaj made
a she made uh she was critical of
Megan's song going as far as to record
her own response diss track called
Bigfoot I mean this is just [__]
stupid you
know I love d songs ever since Tupac
after that it's just like when you
realize it's oh yo hey you're just
rhyming dude hey write a Dr Seuss book
and mail it to them this isn't
hardcore you know it's all a business
right because I mean on one sense it's
hardcore because you're talking [__] to
someone but on on the on uh on the other
hand you
know you're just basically going
grinding finding you're just rhyming you
know um
I don't know I guess she got shot in the
foot
though
so
um she got shot in in a in a foot and
then T Lan went to
jail
um that's
crazy how long she did you get for going
to getting shot in the
foot how many time years is he going to
be in jail to Lan can you look it up I
watched this thing on Netflix The Other
Day toughest prisons and this guy is
like I was I was he goes to different
prisons around the world he's going to
jail for 10 years Jesus he'll probably
do like seven or
eight for shooting a foot what are you
in here for shooting a
foot who's my
girlfriends turn around um and uh pull
your pants down
hey you guys are the [__] thank you for
watching and that's it for for for
YouTube but if you want to watch the
rest of the episode go to
patreon.com and you can get all the
other episodes of congratulations in
their entirety how they're supposed to
be listened to and also you get the uh
extra episode a month which we've been
doing this for what 3 years now you get
all those
free well for $6 if you pay $6 then you
get them free cuz you but you still get
paid you get charge $6 but also you
don't get them free but you get the
extra episodes and nobody else gets them
is what I'm saying so there you go
thanks a lot guys appreciate
[Music]
you